[Music]
i'm standing here with trevor denman
nice to see you sir good to meet you and
trevor you've been calling races in
general for over 40 years 42 years yes
you're going to teach me now the fine
points of calling a race okay i have
about 25 minutes and i think that that's
enough time for me to master what it's
taken you 40 years to perfect
you have a famous catchphrase that you
use when the horses come out of the gate
what is it yep we always say and away
they go now that's yours i have to come
up with my own it would probably be
better being unique is good yes and here
come the horsies
not professional pop goes the weasel
definitely not wham bam thank you man
it's a pony party
put out the biscuits here they come
chicken stew is on the boil
category
do you know these horses blue collar boy
oh yeah good horse oh yeah yeah you can
win public defender
chance yeah small chance yeah but not
great you know what public defender
that's never the best lawyer here he
comes court appointed indifferent
attorney
that's not good
should i comment if there are
celebrities in the crowd yes should i
make up celebrities just to get the
credit excited to do that and we've got
a great day here at santa anita
the uh original nine apollo astronauts
are here
even the ones that are dead
okay the race is in about 33 minutes i
just got
the colors which i have to memorize for
my race
blue collar boy
red so blue is red that makes sense when
you're feeling blue
it's because someone's bleeding blood
that's red
blue is blue is red serengani is blue
seren saringas is deadly
you start to die you turn blue
serengone
ally did it he's yellow ali did it ally
ally you go down an alley you got an
alley to urinate
yellow allie did it knuckle buster
orange knuckle buster knuckles you get
your knuckles orange when you eat a lot
of cheetos
here's the problem they told me that
when the horses get close they block out
those colors and then you have to go by
the colors that the jockeys are wearing
sarangani the jockey will be wearing
white with green war game [ __ ]
i'm back that's disgusting
serengani likes green [ __ ]
do you come here often
i very rarely miss a day now do
celebrities come out to the track often
what kind of celebrities are here you
have to invite jimmy the hat up here
jimmy the hat let me have a little tell
you something about any guy with a
nickname no no probably has a weapon
when someone says you gotta meet my pal
jimmy the hat it means you're
about six hours away from being stuffed
into a trunk well he's a horse player
no he's not a gambler he's someone who
he's one guy right there hi jimmy
give me the hat
look at that guy look
you know where he's going right now
there's a body he forgot to bury
okay uh we're coming down to it trevor
is going to call or announce the first
race and then i'll do the second race
and uh
way they go to a perfect start town bell
showing some speed as well and now
tribal reign in the white blinkers runs
up on the outside and it's gonna be
connect and martin garcia to win it
about four or five in the end
that was incredible easy i can't do that
i'm first of all you're not you're
announcing colors that are the jockeys
uniforms yes i don't know those trevor
just informed me off-camera i thought
that i was only announcing here at the
track but that is not the case this is
going out where well it'll go to the
whole of america it goes to south
america it'll definitely be in england
you'll be in every bedding shop in
england it'll go to france and most of
western europe i wasn't told this and
i'm not kidding around
i just threw up into my mouth
[Music]
the race is about to begin
we're watching the horses come towards
the gate
of course the jockeys are riding the
horses
and not vice versa
everybody seems to be in this white
thing which i'm told is a gate
i'll briefly mention
that conan
is at 11 o'clock on
of
tbs
here we go and it's pancakes on the
griddle as the horses
we've got it looks like blue collarboy
going in strong there's blue collar boy
but it also looks like uh he's a sure
call is doing a good job a bunch of
horses out there hard to see with these
binoculars i'm seeing blue collar boy
i'm seeing a bunch of horses following
blue collar boy all horses look alike
when you're not around horses
and they're closing in fast yes this
race is really up the jockeys bottoms
are in the air which is really the
toughest ride horses bottoms high that's
the way to go boys
here we go now around the last turn here
comes the last journey it looks like
this is an exciting race i think it's
he's a show column blue collar boy if
i'm if i'm wrong i apologize
it's not my fault i don't do this
regularly and here we go it looks like
this is a very exciting race
oh
[Applause]
we gotta get out of here fast
[Music]
[Applause]